you can pick up your slice and you know
it's like pizza on a stick
hey everyone Joe here today I'm going to
be making pizza utilizing tools we found
on the internet seven different Pizza
gadgets and I'm gonna be evaluating them
based on price value and if they
actually make pizza making easier we're
gonna get started all of our Pizza
gadgets we found these on the internet I
want to run through them with you all so
we could see what we're working with
before we get into the pizza making we
got this combo set right here a docker
and what looks like a pizza roller we
have this silicon mat nonstick we have a
pizza cutter we have these pizza
scissors with actually a serving spatula
it looks like I mean come on then we
have these two pizza ovens of sorts one
it looks like a top-down rotating cooker
one looks like a Pac Man like mouth that
will cook the pizza from the top and
bottom at once we'll see how that goes
this little tool I'm very excited to get
to try the future of the spork
this is a pizza cutter and fork in one
[Music]
we're ready to make some pizza we have
our gadgets in the Internet I have two
pizza dough's here we're gonna do them
two different ways one I'm gonna stretch
by hand one I'm going to use these
silicon mats
I'm going to use this pizza pastry
roller combo kit and I'm going to use
the docker
oh it's rather large all of the
different measurements on it seems
pretty practical actually dough feels
great we got it in the center only using
this to roll it out I'm going from the
center out actually kind of like driving
a little toy car around the pizza dough
I don't know if I would ever actually
use this for pizza but a good rolling
tool nonetheless looks like we're nice
and even for the docker normally you
would use the docker pokes little holes
and things so it doesn't puff up when it
bakes so I'm just gonna dock the center
not the edges because I want some sort
of a crack
maybe I'm not using right it's poking a
lot of little holes in here the sauce or
toppings might go through I am going to
dust this with a little flour what a fly
put this here put this here and now for
the moment of truth does it work
maybe sort of kind of oh look at that
peel it's like taking the wrapper off of
a new piece of electronics next pizza
here we're going to do traditional with
my hands so that way we have some point
of comparison as to the two different
pizzas just on my knuckles using the
weight of the dough two pizzas two
different methods time to topping the
cocoa all right we have our two pizza
ovens here very easy to setup this one
had nothing other than a plug this one
here has a hole timer dial an upper a
lower switch just had to plug it in
attach this little rotating thing my
level of optimism on these I'm going
with this one it seems more contained I
know when you're cooking pizza you want
that direct heat this one is like I
could touch I could touch the plate
that's not a good sign
kind of awkward because of this whole
thing right here sure to get a good
angle for the launch starting on one end
right in and now they both started at
the same time so we'll be able to
compare us to which ones cooking faster
or slower
I see reminder the pepperoni one was
made with a docking tool the cheese and
basil was made rolling out by hand I'm
gonna say this one may be done in about
15 minutes this one I'm gonna be
surprised if it's ready in 20 I don't
have high hopes for this one over here
either way we're gonna come back in
about 10 minutes and see how we're doing
this is exciting we're at 8 minutes
right now and this one looks like
there's some good action happening on
top but I'm taking a peek underneath and
we're still very very blonde I could
tell just by touching the dough I'm
gonna go to only lower turn off the top
heating element because I want to let
this ride out the top looks completely
done but I know it's not cooked on the
bottom I like this one just cuz it's
kind of like a surprise you don't know
what's happening and it's like opening a
magical box every time
oh all right the top is done the crust
is still very soft I would love to see
some sort of something to give it a
little texture and hold so it doesn't
just a wet floppy slice no one likes a
wet floppy slice we're partway through
here my thoughts I think I've actually
switched this one seems a little more
promising than my initial reaction this
one will be better
well we'll see how it pans out when
they're both cooked more it's been about
20 minutes this little spinning pizza
guy here we're gonna do a little lift up
the dough is cooked we just have no
color on there but I don't think
anything else is gonna happen this one
over here looks much more promising now
underneath I could feel a bit of texture
I could see some color I think
the pizza is done and we're gonna pull
these out you can see this guy's holding
rather nicely back onto our peel we're
gonna slide him off and you can see this
is still very floppy but that's what
we're testing I'm gonna clear these
almonds out of the way we'll bring in
our cutting gadget so we found on the
internet and do a little taste test
comparison all right we're here I'm
excited to taste us these we have all of
our cutting gadgets now I'm gonna start
with our cheese pizza here and this one
purpose pizza pie cutter it has these
little upper indents I think for your
crust but in reality no one's crust is
really that high or tall we're going to
press and wiggle and nothing happened
yep this is a big piece of junk moving
over here to our other pizza we have a
couple other cutting options I do see
this working rather well very sharp
scissors a little slice tool to grab
your slice when you're done cutting
it'll cut in oh yeah look at that and
then you could pull away like magic and
it acts as a spatula on my way to the
plate you can probably spin in a circle
do a little dance your pizza is not
going anywhere until you're ready for it
there we go we got another slice secured
on my scissors for the final tasting
rather than pick up the pizza and eat it
with my hands like an animal I'm going
to use this futuristic cutting and
eating utensil we're going to try to
there we go and then with one swell
swoop
this is the top-down pac-man cooking
oven while there is some crunch and
texture tastes a little uneven
undercooked chewy
it's definitely edible I don't know if
it's enjoyable we're gonna go over here
to our other one kind of the same effect
still very chewy almost dough in the
center at the end of the day you still
get to eat pizza I'm happy with this
this little cutter I feel like these
should be a staple at every Italian
pizza restaurant throughout the country
I mean you're gonna blow minds
first off this guy here our pizza cutter
this costs online $20 this is a piece of
junk I would not recommend this at all
zero out of zero will go on to our combo
pack this is a docker and the pastry
roller fourteen dollars seven dollars
each not a bad deal I wouldn't
necessarily get them for pizza they're
good all-purpose tool to have in your
kitchen Arsenal will do a breakdown out
of five I give these a three hour pizza
scissors nine dollars I think could be
worth the value if you have a place for
them making the process easier
I'd give them a two and a half out of
five large silicon mat silicon or
silicon silicon silicon as the place
silicon is the mat silicon $20 $19.99 I
think that's a good deal you can use
this for pizza you can use this for
candy you can use this for bread you
could use this for cakes it is all of
the measurements to all of the gram size
breakdowns scale it did make pizza
making a little easier if you're unsure
of how big of a circle or how to keep
things evenly throughout I'm going to go
ahead and give this a four this costs
how much doesn't matter it's totally
worth it this is a five out of five
I'm a sucker for cute adorable fun
things like this and
I think everyone should have one and
there are only six dollars do you
believe that totally worth it
sold starting with this guy I was
calling him the Pac Man pizza oven
$35 uh you know I could see multiple
uses for this on your counter you could
toast bread in it you could do frozen
things I would give it a three out of
five moving on to our other pizza
Spinney pizza + oven cooker Pizza
machine this costs fifty dollars not a
good value I didn't enjoy the way it
worked to me it almost seems like a unit
Oscar takes up a huge amount of space on
your counter and your cabinet the
heating element is only in one part so
things are essentially cooling down as
they're spinning around I'm gonna give
that a 1 alright that's it for today
breaking down all of these pizza gets
you could find on the internet my
thoughts my use my reviews if you guys
are interested in buying any of these
gadgets check out the links below and if
there are any other gadgets or kitchen
tools you want me to review and check
out comment below I'm Joe I love pizza
[Music]
[Music]